chuck was on danced on the stars I don't
know there was one of the one of the
dancers on there you just talked about
how tough he is and it [ __ ] one up
and how I knew all this took Taekwondo
and jujitsu and boxing I guess
everyone's like he's a badass like walk
around like he's a badass yeah and then
chucked him down set no hey Mark uh
Chuck Liddell tell about all the fight
she been like all the fights I guess he
lightly get all this stuff in channel
you do want and the guy was like in
front of every was like nah just messing
around right oh yeah nothing it runs
like what the good answer sir yeah yeah
cuz most people stick with it I thought
people try and stick with it oh yeah but
when you look at how small TJ's
comparison even me I look at him and I
go and I said she's just so much smaller
and you said how do you want to lose how
do you want to lose he'll do whatever II
would blows my mind like it which I do
you think could even attempt a single
like that like uh yeah sure III that and
that's natural cuz you're so much bigger
than a guy like TJ now I know better I
know better I know what he would do kind
to do well I'm he left to it you think
he could that I'm so small joking and
you go I was joking you cuz we looked at
I went when I looked at the picture i
went he's so much smaller and you go
yeah and he's a [ __ ] nightmare to
fight and i go i know i said and then I
just because I wanted to hear how what
you would say I said now how long would
I last you think do you think I'd be
able to get some positions and you go
what how do you want to lose smoke some
that devil's lettuce I got a little out
of control I I might I might start
smoking now that it's legal in
California you might see me high more
often I had a good time not a great I I
don't smoke weed I was laughing hard I
had so much fun and that's what I mean
is you had to follow Theo as well and i
thought i was just nervous and then you
got up and you did really well
legitimately well on your own merit
throwing in jokes had I was gonna slap
your face because I don't you get too
cocky but but it was so is it must have
been a good feeling so Chris cyborg
check this out so you guys know I've
been an advocate of Chris I works for a
while now I'm like dude why is in the
UFC invest in her she's the best female
fighter in the world everyone's scared
of her given
opportunity blah blah blah even at one
let her fight at 145 you make her fight
at 140 the big French of 35 this
ridiculous I even went bad on Dana I
want to apologize to Dana in the UFC
because it came out that she's turned
down two title fights at 145 after Holly
and another girl and she was like no I
can't make that weight in eight weeks
then you shouldn't [ __ ] fight when
you have no you have no room to complain
you have no room anymore to get up she
can't make 145 yes after we did the
companion and I was high as a kite I got
the munchies and I have any groceries at
home and my girl and baby were sleeping
so I can be loud so I took an uber home
like a gentleman because I don't drive
high right and I made him stop at
McDonald's and there's a long line and I
literally ordered oh I don't know six
mcgriddle no two big back so many like
two egg mcmuffins you went crazy
mcflurry went crazy well and then I paid
for every one of the cars behind I paid
for six cards why I don't know as high
happy and just eating mcgriddles and
laughing anybody bertrise barang six
cars behind me hey well not much no I
thought I hey got you back about $46
yeah 22 Long's Jesus Christ for all the
car that's pretty funny that was happy
that's pretty cool that hooked everyone
up that's great felt like fine everybody
I felt like Oprah you get a big mac you
get a big guy you give it all right
thanks like seventy-nine cents I went
home and uh I threw up everywhere after
that guys it's too much food for human
being I felt great going down yep
terrible going back up Wow rough morning
the next morning I can laugh one your
body has like it's you know yeah my big
ass shouldn't be in then well I get
mobbed in Canada dude I get mobbed in
Canada and you should know that you're
mopping can they call me the candidate
kid it's weird cuz in la the people fly
you down for hers and stuff and it weird
last night I went had the pleasure of
sitting through Mary Poppins my daughter
was in it and why I kept smelling I
thought
in dog [ __ ] I was checking my shoes and
then you're out that we keeps New York
the [ __ ] you talkin something's on me it
drives me something's on me yeah and I
figured someone else usually yeah ah but
then you're like with somebody breathing
behind me with terrible Brett what the
[ __ ] is going on right I just couldn't
figure it out and then I just mild my
sweater and I was like I have something
on let me guess yep I love it god your
breath nope your teeth no you [ __ ] it
was your wife no but I did that she was
talking and I was like yeah you have
junk over always talking I was once and
she was what are you gonna go nothing
she goes smells I I was like maybe maybe
she maybe she ate some poo did you order
the pupu platter right but it wasn't her
and then I I look down and I see my son
just sitting there and I go and I hear
it I know I here like right in the
middle play my wife Kristen and I go huh
and another he's just fartin as long as
he can didn't give a [ __ ] and I go hey
man hey man I got a little manners huh I
look whoever has even finding this whole
time and she goes the whole time she
never told me and we started laughing in
the middle of my daughter's place on
stage we start you know when you can't
stop laughing yeah like 22 kids being
adults my own daughters on stage I could
not I could not stop the last 40 then
the kid behind me Rip's one like like if
you were to take a bat and hit a heavy
bag what's wrong with all these [ __ ]
kids money my dad was slap my face they
don't because they're five and they
don't care and they don't know and
they're just like what I have to fart
then they'll say stuff like I have to
poo now yes now like it comes
immediately yeah and you got to run them
to the dirtiest bathroom on the planet
Rob korjev you met Brendan shop cuz he's
gonna be having just gonna let agreed
I'm shaking your hand he's gonna kick
you what its gonna let Kate I'll [ __ ]
fight both of you guys I'll fight both
of you guys do you have an intensity to
your I yeah it's downright scary yeah
yeah yeah all right good interview guys
that's our topic today is the healing us
been great it's been fun it's been
really fun I feel like the last time I
saw you was in Vegas I'll read that
pool party and I don't remember what it
was for you to at a pool party shirt off
in Vegas shirts are probable a couple of
knowing me yeah yeah a couple of medium
white guys with our shirts like a raging
to he and I arms near I'm supplies I've
kept the shirt on right now I went below
we were like hey let's like let's cheat
on our watch those girls have not even
loose stole cars I we built guns quickly
home village room away didn't even shoot
him or when we go to my father's mother
was you know I was her first grandson
and and she was um very this very
dignified woman who lived in Annapolis
and her second husband was an admiral in
the Navy and she was very very cool and
a raging alcoholic so she was the one
she was the one the main voice of like
you know you might you might be the
second come out yeah you got might be
Jesus you got to she would test me give
me water just kami glasses of water and
turn that into why what do you think you
can turn that into nothing ok I keep to
maybe the mall yeah so I I kind of like
had agency may be like a cocky agency
where where when I decide to be an actor
I was like yeah well I never knew
anybody that had done it like nobody
ever left my town but you know why not
wait were you ever in the the service
I'm little some time there him as I was
a was no April so wait what branch army
yeah you know I just did a whole bunch
of stuff man i'm this and that you sound
like a liar no it just sounds like I'm
really lets a little i well i do i get
like that it's only gonna be shitty
terrible okay then let me try Stolen
Valor Stolen Valor have you seen those
videos I can't watch do I love those
videos where they knew they knew it when
they roll up on one would pretend like
well girion he's all for 79 time he's
like I was [ __ ] there yeah what city
is san diego your that's Stolen Valor no
I've out like I've heard all about them
and I just can't I get anxious just
hearing about it like that's so
embarrassing
I saw one where this guy was pretend to
be a Navy SEAL to get chicks just
happens to be he's got a reason why wait
there I me and Jimmy Burke you should do
that I've got this guy just did the
wrong bar he's in san diego where Navy
SEALs like to hang out and go to silver
lake there yeah yeah go back go taobao
assistant tell that story but he's
telling the story and then these real
name SEALs are like oh really you're you
know your fragment you know I do not
stuffing is like still lying to them
like let's talk you outside there's five
of them that's passage it like they're
all legit badasses yeah this guy won't
give it up and they're like you need to
stop this right now and then obviously
it turns out bad absa I'm sure did yeah
cuz then he starts challenging them to
my doc and and it's not like the Navy
SEALs are like Stolen Valor yeah huh now
they're like war get this over guys
nothing that's what out of that he took
like three days of karate and high
schools like I'm just gonna stay with
this yeah I'm Suzy I'm so right just
outside kick hitch a ride this house yet
go